someone on Twitter used Miley Cyrus as
an example of why not today bisexuals
and Halsey isn't having it oh boy over
the weekend news broke about Miley Cyrus
and Liam Hemsworth calling it quits
after less than a year of marriage of
course the internet did what the
Internet does and got to work
weighing in on the split that's when one
Twitter user took things too far
commenting on Miley sexuality if there's
chemistry with someone chemistry with
someone the internet troll wrote that
Miley split from Liam quote confirms why
you shouldn't date by people adding not
offensive just true buy is greedy and
never satisfied that's what Halsey who
like Miley has been open about her
bisexuality chimed in and shut his down
heart she responded quote stop being
afraid of women who aren't afraid to do
what pleases them and not other people
the best part is that at the end she
added an old-school smiley face like a :
- parenthesis it's like I'm gonna shut
you down but keep it friendly loves it
and the internet loves it too fans
instantly praise the singer first
standing up for Miley with one fan
writing in response to her tweet quote
King tell'em while another dubbed her a
feminist queen and another user wrote
amazing women supporting amazing women I
love of course the hateful tweet was a
response to pics that went viral of
Miley locking lips with Brody Jenner's
ex Caitlyn Carter just hours after news
broke that she and Liam had called
things off a rep for the couple told et
at the time quote ever-evolving changing
his partners and individuals they have
decided this is what's best while they
both focus on themselves and careers and
despite their split a source recently
told ET that the two quote love each
other and always will and that most of
their friends believe they'll be back
together
Liam spoke out on Monday sharing this
gorgeous pic of the sunset alongside
option that read in part quote just a
quick note to say that Miley and I have
recently separated and I wish her
nothing but health and happiness going
forward I feel so lucky to be with
someone like her as for Miley she is
ignoring all that chatter on the world
wide web and reconnecting with nature
she shared this pic on Instagram writing
don't fight evolution because you will
never win like the mountain I am
standing on top of which was once under
water connected with Africa change is
inevitable that metaphor though
Bravo girl
the 26 year old is also pouring her
heart out in the studio on Monday Miley
shared this pic
Sam's caption to Twitter take that
broken heart and make it art girl we are
ready for the box until then keep it
locked right here on ET for all the
latest Miley Liam Halsey Brody Caitlyn
news I'm Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]